let's see if we can calculate the fifth
root of 32 so like always pause the
video and see if you can figure this out
on your own so let's just remind
ourselves what a fifth root is so if X
is equal to the fifth root of 32 that's
the same thing as saying that X to the
fifth power is equal to 32 so we have to
find some number where if you take five
of them and multiply them together that
you get 32 so there is a couple of ways
to approach it especially when you're
doing with these really higher-order
roots here so let me rewrite the fifth
root of 32 here one way is you could try
to factor 32 and see is are there
factors that show 5 times and so 32 you
might immediately recognize as an even
number so it's going to be divisible by
2 it's 2 times 16 16 is 2 times 8 8 is 2
times 4 4 is 2 times 2 so in this case
doing the factoring technique worked out
well because we see that this is 2 times
2 times 2 times 2 times 2 or 2 to the
fifth power you could rewrite this as
the fifth root of 2 to the fifth power
which is of course going to be equal to
2 2 to the 2 to the fifth power is 32
now let's do another one it's going to
be a little bit harder all right let's
say we want to take the fifth root of
243 so now a much much larger number so
there's a couple of ways to do this one
you could try the factoring although
it's going to be harder now that it's a
larger number or you could do a little
bit of trial and error you doing higher
roots without the aid of some type of
calculator or something it's a little
bit more complicated so here if we
wanted to do the factoring technique we
could say alright it's not divisible by
two I like to start with the smallest
possible factor so it's not divisible by
two is it divisible by three and you
might be familiar with the
to see if something is divisible by
three you add up the digits and see if
that sum of the digits is divisible by
three so if I were to take two plus four
plus three that is equal to nine and so
it is divisible by three so this is
going to be equal to three times let's
see 3 goes into 240 80 times and then
one so 81 times and so 81 is also
divisible by three I have a sense of
where this is going now
it's 3 times 27 which is 3 times 9 which
is 3 times 3 so using the factoring
method we're able to see that 3 to the
fifth power is 243 so the fifth root of
243 is equal to 3 now another way that
you could have done it is a little bit
of trial and error we already know well
we know that 1 to the fifth power is
just going to be 1 we know that 2 to the
fifth power we just calculated that
that's 32 well we now know what 3 to the
fifth is but let's say we're just trying
to zoom in on it a little bit so let's
say if you wanted to see what 4 to the
fifth is well that would be 4 times 4
times 4 times 4 times 4 so let's see
this is going to be 16 16 times 4 is 64
times 4 is 256 and then that times 4 and
I just happen to know this but you might
want to do it by hand
this is 10,000 and 24 so if you're
taking the cube root of 243 you're
saying hey what to the fifth power
something to the fifth power is equal to
243 and if you have a sense that it's
going to be a integer solution if you
think it's going to be something like a
2 or 3 well then 3 is probably going to
be a good guess here if the possible
answers are going to be decimals then
it's going to be a lot more complicated
but that's another way say maybe I'll
try all three and if you try it out 3
you would get 243